нахиляйте кіно гуйян такої опції на
прокуратура [ __ ] тисяч на раз завалило
а вірно ним з проведення корупції політик
видосик про підпалила силу верховній раді
випромінювання називають шалай несу маяк рагу
це ТС-1 і в цій коробці не прокуратурі
стежка творячи завидно острів заяв
політики аромати ідея че вики різьбленим
своєму за я вам намагатися заробляти
політичний pr
політичні та яким атаки з
політично дивіденди які про важливі
їх ваш курс слідує його skoda року ти і
ну а латина менше 1 і призначаєш ці
права дружини і у нас по газону
реальність сатрапа годину щоб воювати з
документу а ти з цими фактами і довести їх
до суду на седана ви заявив ще до
подачі до суду готувати деки праворуч
самі клави плану та перикарду ти вже
встановлена ​​велика хвороба цієї позики на
правом у 3 хворих акти видно
ось хлопці категоріях праворуч c і в одне
але судді загиблих схованки було подібне до нього
і каротином і
видно що вже насправді до суду
справа видно знову кераміка вологжан і
одній установці та кабановій страті кістка
його на суму читається мільйонів гривень
ось ще на підході він і був ще 34 до 30
днями ще держави кінні c ви можете
290 to the card матеріал праворуч та
повні мудаки зациклений на право тягнув
викупить і право дуже чий srx exprof
розправи прогрітої плутати верховної ради
але прикладами рук новинка була пара
порошенко Сергій Пашинський народний
фронт та циклу мартиненка
до зайві депутація! даний час кошти
у всіх під їхні права дуже відриваючи pocky
shock [ __ ] нікому не волошину відриваючи
стадія збору дакозавр бази мові відразу
депутата попередня
та не позичив у верховної ради на
протягнутий край по дальності та владна
там таких складний процес і шитко
результату чика ти не war такі ціни
можна і такі справа справа д.е.
системна корупція дає за діяння
офшори тіньові схеми ви не зажадали
годині зажадаєте захисних за син і онук
вона так моя міжнародних партнерів
прем'єра розлучиться континентальні 1
рівно вази інновації в колі різанини
політичні промови тепер є вся
інформація у нас їжі ці права дуже а
якби 120 зараз такі
пов'язані за корупцію до нас чисел циклу
так тому
з навушники ми не можемо заразна порід
створ чого ти про на я поза списком для
притиснутий [ __ ] темп меншим
міністром вона стрибала через а нам
кабміну кошти відриває закриваючись
обер документі обер до case
які взаємо обоє зараз узус in a лайки
трава і зроблений місця
економіка абрамовича з придушити ставку
видавилося що це зтопити стали його
публічно заяви
буду це перегріта висунути і ви на
машині я посилаєте тебе перевірка якщо
заявка містера абрамом години детективи
манабу було зареєстровано crema
праворуч і міністр вже таких як
раз побував над дослідами будуть досвід та
нардеп кононенко праві кавказу міністр
оманливо своїх заявок заява річки
виникають ближній сфері і потім дуже
важко подвоїться государ
їжу живуть в голові прапор виходить на
фінішну пряму
всі відходять вашим противником начебто
як ще й таких на зафіксувавши а на ваш
адреса
alexander hotto листування facebook видно
видом у когось мозку то шеннон відходи
як виходу я ваш робочий день татарських
ліквідний вибрати вид на пружину
виглядаю робітник до нього фігні
хлопчик sepo прийшов крим окремих
зв'язок ми на роботі було і на прикладі
їм нульові лінійки більше також довелося
перервати на роботі мови в судових
датського харчування для хлопця звуть зазвичай
заходив нести правоохоронець та олег
підкоряється і засуджувати деві тяги у всіх
olap життя закінчився мій гінеколог че
виточує вище ніж сьогодні в ясна
не можна навіть на вигляд президента бен
адже генпрокурора праці
моя чіткого позиція на листи на заражати
то мою роботу народом свою роботу і
коротко я може згортати ще диску
черепаха незаконних цих із приводу
тисяч за право дуже nebula
навіть я до такої